what we've got here is a piece of
software that Martyn Poliakoff of
periodic videos commissioned back in the
80s enabled people their level students
to test their chemistry knowledge and if
you look on po2 videos clips they were
running out of storage space you'll see
a video where Martin and I get this up
and running on the BBC micro and
actually started working it was an
interesting exercise and all have a
later how we can actually get the
software off the BBC my car onto
something that we can run on a modern
computer a PC and Mac even a iPhone or
anything else which has got the right
sort of emulator it's relatively easy to
look at images and videos and those
sorts of things but programs are harder
right most images perhaps and this is
perhaps not necessarily a good idea we
tend to compress so we compress them so
they take up less space and so we also
like a JPEG we can access it because
it's so ubiquitous we can just access it
but I shoot raw my SLR thinking about it
I'm not so certain that 22 years down
the line RAW files will be that easy to
access now chances are I shoot with a
pretty common canon DSLR so chances are
that yes that will still be supported
but it's making me think about it
actually should I go and convert them
into something more convenient so it's
counterintuitive in some respects so
you're all shooting raw to preserve as
much possible quality as you can and
actually you might preserve the files
for longer if you put them into a
compressed format because they're more
common exactly so it's best keeping them
in both and it's actually the same for a
piece of software so we need to be able
to decode the data so to any media we
need to be able to decode it and use it
now for something like an image file for
a video that's a relative
straightforward you could write one when
it gets to something like Martin's
chemistry games we can access the data
on the disk we can start to see what
some of these are this looks like it's a
basic program so that's later than that
so that's one of the programs now let's
have a look at some of the others so
this obviously looks like the periodic
table calcium
titanium I suspect this is the one that
you had to guess what was in there we
could start to see what's going on here
and start to see bits of it because we
can understand it seems you compressed
it you need to know how it's compressed
before you can run it so it's a good
argument that you should keep your data
in an uncompressed format but then of
course that takes up even more space and
storage is plentiful but it's not
exactly cheap so you probably do want to
compress it but if you're going to do
that do it in a file format that will be
common
I mean text files put them inside dot
zip files don't use some weird and
wonderful wacky compression format that
you've found that will save you one
percent extra on the file size ten years
down the line chances are we'll probably
still be able to unzip a zip file
possibly not the weird and wacky format
that you might have used when it comes
to programs though in a system like this
not only we need to copy the data and
the program we also need to emulate the
complete system that we're going to run
it on so for example if I want you to
get Martin's games working on my Mac or
on a PC and not only do I need to copy
the data off of this disk and that in
itself is an interesting issue because I
have a five and a quarter inch floppy
drive in the BBC micro but I don't have
one in my Mac and I don't have a USB
file recording to swap it over then we
take say that the probably never been
one producing yep three-and-a-half inch
floppy drives with the USB output but
not five and a quarter so we still need
to find an interesting way of getting
the data off now we could find a PC with
a five and a quarter inch floppy drive
I've gone over there the drive doesn't
work unfortunately but we then need to
write software to understand the disk
format what I actually did to do this is
this machine is networked this is an
earlier networking system called aconite
which acorn developed which I can then
get it onto the archimedes and then
that's got a three and a half inch
floppy disk drive which I can use a PC
format to copy it over to the Mac so if
we look here I wrote this program what
this actually does is it reads each
sector sector by sector track by track
off the floppy disk we get there and we
just write it out to a file
one sector after another and we store it
on the network until eventually we've
got a copy of the file sitting on the
archimedes in this case it's called
CEM image and cam teedo image I then
copied them via a floppy disk onto my
Mac using the floppy drive over here and
then I can use a BBC emulator how many a
relators can you run at the same time
quite a lot in fact I have a machine
running a BBC emulator and a Mac plus
emulator mt4 and an immediate emulator
at the moment so you can run quite a lot
on a standard machine then that was
really a full speed but you can get
things there modern machines can emulate
these things pretty well I've taken an
open-source emulated for the BBC micro
called B BAM I didn't write it I just
hacked it to run nicely on my Mac and so
if we start the emulator and we can boot
it and we should see exactly the same
software running on the modern computer
but again we're having to take it and
emulate the whole machine to it so when
we archive software we probably want to
at least archive something that can run
the software as well in this case an
emulator will be sufficient and you can
write these emulators anything there's
even a JavaScript BBC micro emulator
which means that we could put this in a
web page and then you'll be able to run
it off that sound computer was a lot
more visceral in those days they made
noises and so it's not quite centered on
the screen